- [Gary] When I think about
life, I think about so many
different things that can
factor into winning the day,
winning the year,
winning the game.
The five rules that I live
by are confidence.
Honestly, I think self-esteem
and confidence is the
ultimate drug in society and
keeps most of us away
from losing scenarios.
Positive vibes only
is a huge one for me.
It's not "Positive vibes",
it's "Positive vibes only."
And that's because too many
people are keeping people
around them that are
bringing them down.
They're allowing negative
energy to dictate their outcome
and I really believe that
people have to cut out
negative vibes
in their environment.
Strengths over weaknesses
is a big one for me.
I preach this all the time.
Triple down on what
you're good at.
The world's gonna
tell you to fix this,
you're not as good at that.
I just don't believe in that.
Figure out what you're best at
and keep crafting that craft.
Do it over and over and over.
Legacy over currency.
Understand that in 20, 30,
40, 50 years from now
you're going to care much
more about what people
thought of you, what your
kids thought of you,
what the world thought of you.
Did you do it the right way?
The dollars, the products,
the house and the car,
whatever the monetary
things that don't
matter long term that
you're striving for now.
Don't worry about
your bank account,
worry about how many people
show up to your funeral.
And hustle, my friend.
Number 5, hustle.
If don't work hard,
you've lost.
There's not a single
winner on Earth
that took it easy.
There's not a single
winner on Earth
that didn't
hustle 24/7/365.